[音楽]
こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんは
ポケモンカードをご存知でしょうか今ここ
に最近発売されたポケモンカードの最新作
ポケモンカード古代の方向というパックが
あるんですけどもこちら100ボックス
ゲットしまし
た嘘ですこの中には僕の古代の方向もある
んですけれども1人で100ボックスは手
に入れられません今回ですね古代の方向を
ゲットしたポケカプレイヤー100人に
集まっていただいてみんなの古代の方向を
一斉100人で開封したいと思いますもう
毎回やってます結構最近出てるポケカで
毎回やってるんですけれどもやっぱ
おもろいのよみんなで100ボックス
あげると1人で1ボックス開けるより
なんか100ボックス開けてる感覚を
楽しめるので今回もこの古代の方向を
100人で100ボックス開けていきたい
と思いますこれでも実質100ボックス
開けている気持ちになりますポケが1
ボックス開けるとSRっていうなんか光り
方がすごいカードが1枚運が良ければ2枚
入ってるんですけれども中にはちょっとこ
人気のないカードとかめちゃくちゃ人気で
価値の高いカードとかあると思いますが
100ボックスあるとどのカードがどれ
くらい入ってるか分かると思うのでそこも
ぜひ楽しんでいきましうんそこもぜひ
楽しんでいきますでは古代の方100
ボックス開封行ってき
[音楽]
ますそれで
はポケモンカード古代の
方向100ボックス開封を始めるおすおす
ペラペラ開封
おいい音だみんな準備はできたかではSR
枠が出たものから手をあげて
くれ開封
開始1泊目
[音楽]
お
ああお
おす結構出てますね最初から他に出たもの
はいないか見ていき
ましょう
おすお願いし
ます1発目
ですゴマ
と
いきなり金色スタートですおす
[音楽]
おす千里
SR千利はちょっと笑いが起きるみたいな
感じですかねす
[音楽]
す
ああソ武者EX
SRおす
[音楽]
おす
おおアゾ
XSRすお願いし
ます
ああグレーンアルマSR
2パック目
お
うんおすおすお何が出るか
な
おお博士
の被ってない
ね
おおのEX
SRめっちゃかっこいいおめでとうござい
ますおすおす
おお任せの気
Sおす
おす
おグマ
SR3枠
目さあそろそろ
つきEXのSARかメロのSARが見たい
[音楽]
なお
SR
[音楽]
スル4番目
お
うんなかなかトップレアが来ませんねおし
おしお願いします
おわデカ
exs
おおおグレアX
SRグレンアルマがすごい出てる気がする
とおす
おすおおソ武者EX
SAR
すごいいいな初SARですねよしみな
頑張っていく
ぞ
コパいやなんかそろそろ来そうな気が
するあまだでした今のところですけどいつ
もよりちょっと出が悪い気がしてる
そろそろねトップレア1人2人出る頃なん
です
[音楽]
けどSR出た
人
オンリー
[音楽]
ワンおすおすお願いしますお願いし
ます
おおアマージEX
SR6パ目
お
あまだですねおしおしおしおすすごい
すごい結構出てる
おすおすおすえすごくないどんだけ出てん
の
おおメノコ
SRおうございますおお願いし
ます博士の
SR願し
ますグソEX
SRおすおすおお願いし
[音楽]
ますオーム剥せる企画
SちょっとずつSが出てきてますね
お
あ
[笑い]
珍しいグソムEXSRおお願いし
[音楽]
ますグレマX
SRグレアルめっちゃ多いねお願いし
ます
おおメノコ
SR
[音楽]
おくつき
SRグレンアルマX
SRえグレアルマ多くないみな速報だ
グレーンアルマEXSRが5枚出て
いるなるべく抑えるんだ7パック目
おしうわ俺もまだ出ないなおす
[音楽]
おす
おおゴージャスマントURおす
お砂の怪我
exsおす
おすデカン
SR8枠目おまだですねトッププレアが出
ないぞ見たいっすね見たい
ねおし1バッ目オンリーワンですねおお
願いしますそろそろやっちゃってください
ごめんなさいごめんなさいごめんなさいっ
て言っ
てる
で
よしグレー
アバ
やばいすごいぞちょっと9パ
目頼む来い来い
来いいやまだかおすお願いし
[音楽]
ます
何何やったった何やった
[音楽]
た
ようやく来ましたねトロクツエのSAR
じゃおめでとうござい
ますすす
っと別の
パメルコ
[音楽]
S
[拍手]
[音楽]
スク
だけ2連続でましたプレメロのSAR
ありがとうござい
ますビッグネムに乗るしか
[音楽]
ね
おつ
xurアマージ
SR一気にトップレアが2種類出た
[拍手]
ぞこの調子でどんどん開けていきましょう
10パック
目まだです
[音楽]
[拍手]
ねおすおすグレアルマX
SRおすおす
ますロTX
SR
ボスおおフリム博士の気迫SRおす
おすAmazon
XSRおすすお願いし
ますグレンアルマ
XSR11パッ目
おまだ来ないなさあSR出たものいないか
おすオン1かなおすし
[音楽]
ますおト
XSR12パック目
おまだ
だ可愛いおす
おすこれどうですか
砂の毛EX
SAR
XSRおすおす願し
ますXSR
おす
amsr
[音楽]
お
グレ
アルマ誰かグレンアルマのボスを止めて
くれ今グレンアルマ10枚出て
ます本当にやばい13パック
目
おじゃちょっと僕最後にさしていただき
ます
おおします
船の毛EXSRおす
おすおお結構出てるなPXSRおす
おす
お目の子SRおすおす
おおり任せの白
Sト付のSRも結構出てますね行かせて
いただきます
グレーアルファ来い行き
ます
お
おグレアまでやって
くれ
14パック目おまだら2枚箱の可能性を俺
は忘れないぜそろそろ2枚箱を出てきそう
ですねお
[音楽]
おおすおす
おお
ロおす
おす出てる付きSRおす
すスカEX
SRおすおす
おお不足武者EX
SARトップレアがなかなか出ないですね
2枚が今回トップて言われてるので結構
難しいかもしれませんがグレーンアルマと
ト付きがめちゃくちゃ出てる15パク目お
2枚箱2枚箱2枚箱2枚箱2枚箱2枚箱
[音楽]
くそ
え
ゼロ誰もおらののかSRでなもの
は
ゼロというわけで半分終わりましたまだ
SR出てないよって人どれぐらいいますか
めちゃめちゃおるいやまだ全然楽しめそう
ですねよし後半も気合入れてあげていくぞ
お16白目お2枚2枚2枚2枚2枚2枚箱
2枚箱2枚
箱おおしお2枚箱
おお2枚箱2枚
[拍手]
箱おおおおお
[音楽]
おおすおすバおめでとうござい
ますあおすおすます願し
[音楽]
ますドキ
XSおしますし
ます金生
[拍手]
せや2連続だよ録犠牲あるみんな来てるよ
し
ますやってくださいいや任せて
[音楽]
くださいグレアY
XSR
おすいいテた
ね
おお可愛いやつだ花の毛がYX
SARしますおおくEXSR
目2枚箱2枚箱2枚箱2枚箱2箱2箱2
箱
おソEX
SRおすおお願いし
ます
連続
SR18パ
目枚箱2枚
箱
[音楽]
[拍手]
T
おお願いし
ますグソEX
Sおす
おす砂川EX
SR
おお
ます戦
[音楽]
あるお
お
おメルコ
S
おいいTシャ
[音楽]
だありがとう
ござおすすおオ博士のSR
おすおすおおトつき
XSRおすamaz
SR19パ
目2枚箱2枚箱2枚
[拍手]
[音楽]
箱
お願いしますじゃ行きますうわ初です基本
悪
エネルギー
めっちゃ
綺麗初だここに来
て20パク目お
カ
exr
おす砂の毛EX
SR
[音楽]
おす
ちなみにまだSR出てない人あ結構いるな
残り10パクです行きましょう21パ目お
2枚2枚
[音楽]
はい
お
[音楽]
まずい波が来てる
理し
てめっちゃメロ好きだった
[音楽]
もん
おオリム博せの気迫
SR22パ目おおすあお客に正解でグレア
マ
SRおおああAmazonEX
SRお
お
たあ6EX
[拍手]
[音楽]
Sおすおお願いしますお願いしますいいT
シャツだ
[音楽]
ム博の
SRまずいぞみん仙人の波が来てる23パ
目すかなき
ます願し
ます目お2枚箱おお2枚
[音楽]
[拍手]
箱
願いし
ますわ博士の
[音楽]
迫お一両隣千利です
けど2枚
箱
おめでとうございます
ありがとうわすげ
メロ
おすお博士の
SR
[音楽]
お
おうござい
ますそろそろネタ切れです
おす
SRおすおす任せの迫
Sし
ます任せの企
S25パ目お2枚箱おお2枚
[拍手]
[音楽]
箱おめでとうござい
[拍手]
ますうわあメノコ
SR今箱2枚
[音楽]
箱おござい
ますおお基本悪
エネルギー2枚箱2枚
箱子さんも一緒ですね
[音楽]
渡
[拍手]
[音楽]
よおおありがとうございますあとござい
ますソムEX
SA俺ますおす
おすゴージャスマウント
URおすおすおグソさ
SRおす
おす続だムEX
SR26目
お2枚箱2枚箱2枚
箱2枚箱待って何人いるの3人2枚
[拍手]
[音楽]
箱ああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ありがとうござい
ますおレスカ
SRおオ博せの気迫
[拍手]
SRおめでとうございますおうございます
グアルマ
XSRおす
[音楽]
おすはあって言って
さお
すボスの司令
S27番目
お
[音楽]
2枚箱2枚箱2枚箱2枚箱多く
[拍手]
ない
おめでとうございますありがとうござい
ますお願いし
ますあ驚つき
SRおうござい
ますAmazon
XSRおす
おす次XS
[音楽]
おす砂の毛
SR28パ
目
あす
[音楽]
博の
SRオーム博士めっちゃ出てるね29パ
[音楽]
目2枚箱2枚
[拍手]
箱
[音楽]
ます
おすごいてる博の気
SR次がラストのパックだが
まだSRが出ていない
もの立って
くれお4人彼らが最後まで生き残った
四天王
だ
先に残りの人で最後のパック開けましょう
2枚ぼの可能性もあります3パック
目頼頼む頼む頼むでした2枚
箱大丈夫でし
た大丈夫そうかなよしでは最後のSR見て
いき
ましょうお願いし
ます
[拍手]
メア
ですお願いし
ます
[音楽]
おおトエ
Sラストでございますよろしくお願いし
ます願いし
ますて
ください砂の怪我EX
[音楽]
[拍手]
S疲れ様でし
[音楽]
た
皆さんお疲れ様でし
た100箱の開封結果お知らせしたいと
思いますえまず2枚箱出た人100人
中14人14箱出まし
た結構出てる気がしますSR枠の枚数
100箱回復した結果お知らせしますメロ
のSR7枚えオム博士のSRが11枚え
千里のSRが12枚と結構出てましたでト
付EXのSRが15枚めっちゃ出ました
登録付き砂の怪EXSR5枚グソEXSR
8枚amEXSR10枚デカンEXSR7
枚えグレンアルマEX最後ちょっと
落ち着いて13枚でし
た続いてUR
ですEXのUR2枚ゴージャスマントの
UR3枚基本悪エネルギーのUR2枚と
バランスよく出てましたグソ武者EXの
SARが4枚砂の毛皮EXのSAR3枚ト
付EXのSARがなんと4枚オリムハセの
S5枚そしてメコSが3枚出ましたあの
めっちゃバランス良かった
[拍手]
です
じゃあ次は未来でお会いしましょう